welcome to this video playing naki sauce
from Greece there's no name but he's got
really high rating him okay I never
played him interesting I don't know who
that is
okay let's play my old line there that I
know it's not so great but at least I
know well okay
and why does not have to play d5 yes but
he did okay one thing I can't really be
sure I will be quick in this in this
position I really played this so often
it's sick but I came you know Bishop h6
I really considered to be a mistake to
be honest but it's not it's not terribly
terribly bad or anything I think that
okay wait wait wait let's think about
this for a moment he's attacking b5 b6
yeah I think would be sixes okay want to
trade rooks if possible okay
okay probably him
and then see how I can trade rooks
I'm going I'm trying to play rook e8
okay he tries for before okay so which
we you get this now I can trade one held
ropes is going for head a cup of
maneuver I am okay this is the famous
cup of indica bishop the game that I
featured in on my channel ok I don't
think it's it's a huge issue but let's
see I have to be a bit commercials about
play Queen c7 he has Bishop d6 ok ok -
Bishop c7 ok one that's strongly not bad
for me probably
but I don't I don't really need to do
that again I can also just do this this
kind of funky regrouping here
the bishop coming to b8 at the end the
solo line is kind of strange because it
looks totally ugly but it is kind of
resilient it's not easy to break down
and if I get most things traded I'm
really okay it's it's so it's just like
that
okay so what is this exactly to see I
don't know I don't know if I take a five
I mean taking with the pawn is not
really an idea and g5 really might take
whenever it gets cleaned yet gets this
thing back right okay I'm starting with
that B takes I cannot believe it all so
this and now if I take their what is the
point at the end that's night age five
or what exactly and and this is hanging
on age three right check I don't really
get anything of that it's so what's
happening here if I go Bishop g4 G takes
f a-- teak i can also just play
ninety-eight what is the what is this
reply against that I don't know
okay and now I'm doing Bishop g4 what is
this what is this idea Rukh f7o what I
don't know
let's check this um let's say I take f6
look f17 f7 there's nothing right okay
he just blundered the h2 in porn ready
hmm Jack I hope I'm not blundering
something back king cakes why not Queen
b6 okay I can take it okay that's no big
problem so this is checking here rook d7
looks awkward
you will play whoops e6
I don't know I can go Quinn d8 okay
hmm can't beat down on time that's the
main concern Queens unify if those kind
of thing it might be might be a bit
awkward and I cannot trade time money
cannot treat the rook easily
unfortunately I'm preparing possibly
Knight g4 here okay awkward pen near the
time situation is awkward but still I
mean I can play rook a8 next right and
trade this rook I don't want it wrong
after he blundered the h3 pawned these
pieces are not very threatening at the
moment
oh that's nice nicely played get the
bishop check at the bishop there
yeah it's tricky with the charm
position is very okay really is but well
20 seconds is it's not very much check
now okay I will lose that on time he was
completely completely outplayed in this
game but you have to have to do it in
the right time okay i blundered this
night black resigns yeah I just was far
too slow them here I'm just I'm just
winning with the next report there's no
question about that but I have to
coordinate my pieces right and I did not
I did not manage in time really it's um
it's just a question of how to do it
right I think I was okay mostly when
when the roofs were traded it was really
it was really okay I think this was a
good way to find counterplay though
maybe even Jam I don't know it was
difficult in a practical game with low
time I don't know maybe I should play
more maybe I can play more actively that
that sets maybe um maybe a mistake that
I made like here look here Bishop back
and then trying to attack I mean my king
is arguably the safer one yeah that is
probably the winner actually yeah just a
matter of what is doable in this time
they could the computers are minus one
point four and stuff but yeah you have
to do it in the in the given time what
you really did well what's assume this
is this Bishop g4 shots that was routed
it was really nice I mean I could have
made a draw anyway all the time but I
did not want to this is a nice move
check
and yes some some kind of play there
when I arrived there I don't know yeah
well he'll me at 18 18 seconds so it's
it's it's it's it's it's useless to
analyze even here black is better
it um it was really a thing about an
equal ish position this this is really
not there's not much happening here it
looks like white is better because of
the space but there's not much happening
here after after those trades here and
then G fire g5 is just the blunder what
can you do I can just check Jake take
that and and and bet him he has to he
has to play a some slowish move iam and
white really doesn't have anything much
here because I get the rooks traded on
the a file and I have the dark squared
bishop traded and when that happens not
much not much trouble for black really
if you want to look at this structure
you can look at my do a commentary blitz
match against Greg Shahadah why I got
the rooks traded and then Queens traded
and wonders endgame which is not
necessary who like does not need to win
this and game a draw is probably the the
right term the right kind of result but
nothing really is going on there I mean
you should play any normal move that
same I know what not the computer wants
to play 91 to have H 5 out of the
equation completely but I don't know
probably other moves do do suffice as
well it's just equal and after that I
should win but I really had one mistake
and played this too passively this is
really really really the case
this is a super strong move that I did
not see wow that's very computer ish but
check then 95 and black wins totally now
okay now that sits difficult with little
time even with more time I think I'm
getting me satisfied them with the start
of it but I should really not start here
I should go here and here and try to do
something myself especially considering
the the lower time situation I was
always a bit afraid to do this kind of
thing because he has this Czech Knight G
3 to 5 but this is not really a big
issue after age 6 now that was much
better playing more actively I was a bit
too passive there it it was keeping an
edge but it wasn't the best is to play
more actively him okay well thanks for
watching